[Music]
Brian John yes your name is John and
Briana but your name is Gregg Alva we're
the real rejects John yes have you heard
of a show called Family Guy yes I have
the reservation show called American Dad
I've seen some episode have you heard of
a show called The Cleveland Show
yeah they euthanize my king of the hill
favorite session well John what do they
all have in common they're all created
by Seth MacFarlane and they're all
animated shows yes you know what's
interesting about this this is also
created by Seth MacFarlane but it's live
action oh man and stars none other
Patrick Warburton that's a corporate
Seth MacFarlane what oh wow okay only
thoughts still love it hello like a Star
Trek kind of scoop show okay and we know
he loves his Star Trek and Star Wars
thing and we know he loves his Cosmo
show every at Cosmo again it likes be
sure that you produce what it's like a
document I forgot was cold Oh cosmos
yeah I said Cosmo bottom like an old guy
like who's God what does he want from me
see my good news is a ship available the
USS sword oh well ever since I was a kid
I have wanted to serve an exploratory
Buster nobody's first choice for this
job but we have 3,000 ships to Staten we
need captains nobody's missed those are
Marvel's we're giving you one last
chance
so I'm starting Jon Favreau's day I am
thrilled to be using captain I want this
to be an efficient ship but also one
that you're glad to be serving on
Lieutenant Commander boardís your entire
species is male
that is correct probably not a lot of
arguments about leaving the toilet seat
up and that kind of thing
welcomes urinate only once per year
really that's I'm up to three times a
night it is unfortunate it is neat the
locals hi I'm captain ed Mirza holy crap
we don't need your family anymore when
we did you just an aside from shooting
your dad we don't mean your family
coming in from Admiral Halsey
it doesn't an executive officer's become
available no no no no no sorry man you
okay yeah it's so good man you okay
y'all goats I don't worry the captain
does not appear to be pleased to hear
why do this first officer they were
married no way you know any time to talk
to you want to suggest a couple people
the therapist was your brother-in-law it
should be really fun trip for all of us
perhaps we should not be talking about
this one and we're talking about them
this is the thing you'll be delivering
supplies to the science station on
epsilon 2
thank you for coming we need protection
protection for what the curtain we have
figured out a way to manipulate the
scene of event so it's an anti banana
ray it's really interesting we need no
longer fear the banana I design offers
about the salad
you do realize these cookies does weapon
that's why okay what if the captain
nurses just detected a krill destroy of
entering orbit
I understand plus good open this jar of
pickles for me loosened it for you
return fire give me the device or it
will be scrolling you're sorry can move
like two steps to your right it's just a
lot of dead space than perfect gaps are
you were just very weirdly friends with
that good beer
I am nervous you know the new ship wanna
make a good impression it's 9:15 in the
morning sorry I have thoughts I have
thought I thought I thought hot ok
definitely doesn't look hilarious
alright it doesn't look like this is
going to be a laugh riot I feel like the
humor here would work better if it'd
look like an actual cool [ __ ] as opposed
to oh it's a spoof of Star Trek you know
because that's pretty much all we got
it's a Star Trek to sit straight up a
Star Trek movie now yeah all the designs
and everything and the jokes they're
regular making fun of us all started
look it's all Star Trek parody related
the jokes I didn't feel really landing
because the actual show itself in terms
of sci-fi or actions that doesn't really
look that exciting or cool yeah like if
garden to the galaxy was only trying to
be funny it probably wouldn't work but
it's really funny and hilarious because
it's got a bunch of other cool stuff
that balances it all out
yes here we're just getting the comedy
the spoof and that doesn't look
hysterical so it doesn't make me feel
like I have to really watch this show
there's kind of a little bit of a
letdown because I love all the family
guys who she does a Star Trek I think
those are all really funny I know he was
worked with Patrick Stewart plenty of
time knowing and I thought it would have
been cope we got a little cameo for
Patrick Stewart aboard or something like
especially because it's definitely not
shy of hiding the fact that it's just a
straight-up Star Trek spoof and it looks
like to be funny it was we gonna be
entertaining it looks like you could
have a chuckle yeah I don't feel like
I'm gonna be really like yeah he's like
seven MacFarlane Jon Favreau Graham I
didn't know anything about it but from
seeing what the setup wasn't in seeing
the two and a half minute trailer we got
the little letdown to be honest
interesting I mean we're coming from two
different places on this it could I like
I enjoy episodes Family Guy enjoy merica
dad but you are a set mcfarland fan much
more than Arya as I am I I even like a
million ways diverse beauty yeah here's
evidence where I'm gonna get out like I
prefer him animated to light I like a
million ways design the left out I was
interesting watching well I saw it when
it came out on HBO now uh-huh
you banged your wife I saw that film
yeah some of the stuff you mentioned
some of things you don't like as much or
things I do like about this but I do
agree with youth like the end of the day
with this trailer there's a lot of stuff
sighs surprisingly like but I don't know
exactly what makes it special other than
it might be likable yeah like it might
be enjoyable it might be fun I might
grow to enjoy these character than this
version but what are you adding that's
uniquely yours just because like
nostalgia as well and and what I like so
much like oh cool you're doing creatures
and your suits and sets and stuff and
there's some CG here yeah but it happy
they're spoofing like og Star Trek it's
not you know like the later Star Trek
installments or the movies are doing
like like with Captain Kirk instead yeah
yeah it's like nostalgia is opened up
this weird door where now we can kind of
do these shows again if we've got enough
enough of a modern spin to keep them
relevant the other thing I couldn't get
out of my mind during this trailer the
whole time was Galaxy Quest because like
the second that one who showed up in the
middle with like the the shell shaped
head I was like just a galaxy-class way
to see but just across is a great point
yeah I think there were a great film to
bring up because that film was also
exciting and adventurous and funny yeah
this seems to only be relying on trying
to be funny
look exciting and it doesn't look
adventurous and I feel like the funny
would be more had especially with the
kind of easy Seth MacFarlane these are
pretty simple Seth MacFarlane kind of
humor that they're that are showing us
in the trigger I know you have to give
this act I'm the kind of guy that will
just because assess MacFarlane I'm going
to give an episode of the pilot whenever
a chance yeah it's just right now I'm
not I'm not exactly like thrilled about
it you know what else to think too about
like Indiana Galaxy Quest Orville
comparison like Galaxy Quest also has
that I don't know if it's like truly
meta but it has that meta angle of like
oh this is a Star Trek type TV show that
then becomes the real life track and
this kind of had that feel like the
wackiness that comes out of that but
without the whole caveat that gets you
there it feels like a wacky old sci-fi
show I guess hopefully it's good hey I
know a few pairs like guardians and
Galaxy Quest Witcher which are movies
much bigger budgets where you could do
the exciting adventurous stuff a lot
more yeah then you could do on like a
Fox TV show a love-in Seth MacFarlane
material when she randomly does
something badass like I love those
Family Guy episodes where they get into
a fight scene and you're like look
pretty cool fight yeah and even in Ted
when Ted and Mark Wahlberg have that
fight in the apartment yeah real FISMA
yeah yeah I like I like those touches of
it oh he knows how to actually make it
kind of cool like for real cool we'll
just think about Seth MacFarlane that
I've always liked I get some of the
things people don't like about him I
don't like him all the time but what I
always appreciate is that like beyond
all the wackiness and stuff like that
and some of the blue humor like he does
seem like a sharp dude you know Emily
and and this is a good environment for
that like even though there's spoofing
Star Trek like Star Trek also was able
to at least use these space metaphors
for interesting story yeah and because
he produced cosmos like I don't think
this is going to start dispensing wisdom
but like because shows like Rick and
Morty exists that are like edgy comedies
that also just happen to drop in actual
sci-fi yeah that's a cool opportunity I
think this has I don't know if they'll
take
I didn't get anything from the actual
character stuff for this trailer other
than the comedy of vibe you know yeah I
got the vibe the comedy but I don't know
anything about how they're going to tell
their story or what comes towards ya or
even if it is going to be serial you
know maybe this is just episodic okay
yeah I mean it's a stupid Star Trek it
will be that you know episodic serial
kind of format it yeah you know we're
like a hybrid of that like a season are
the disasters every day yeah yeah yeah
there's space exploration and also you
know the fact that Stefan phones not
directing it gives you more faith in his
performance because I imagine like a
million ways to die in the West when
you're like your first live-action role
and tightening it felt much it's harder
to do a good job in acting when it's
like you're especially is your first
time doing it you know you're where so
much going on while you're in front of
the camera I imagine be easier for him
to just be in the scene and not worry
about directing at the same time you
know yeah well it is if he's a good
actor I think I his voice acting is
really good and you got crapper his
performance on million ways to die in
the West I felt like this doesn't mean
you'd be bad if someone else was
directing you know one maybe and maybe
Seth MacFarlane the director
overindulgence and doesn't know how to
make himself look as good as they are
for director money that is the other
thing that since you brought up that I
you know I'm really interested in about
this is to see him work with a new team
we're got like this you know who at
least keep an eye on I'm always
interested to see what they'll be like
with a new team of people and that's
true like if he's just in the writers
room it is acting maybe this will bring
a new vibin and his performance would be
that much fun mess is the lead of a show
man good show I guess I just feel like
if you're going to be on TV you got to
be something that will definitely hook
people because Peters there's TV has a
reputation for being great right now as
opposed to like big movies like you're
more questionable about but TV is do a
really excellent job these days well and
there's so much of it and to hear it's
like it but it seems more like a long
sketch yeah that's yeah like I like I
mostly liked this like I enjoyed
watching the trailer enjoyable but yeah
I'm like what is going to keep this from
just being this joke and I do I
know him a little bit and I don't know
if it will be more than that Joe they
spend money on this it seems like those
affect or a lot better than I thought
they had jon favreau ball like this
should be good position so hopefully it
is let's check on the pilot for sure
yeah that was first couple episodes at
least the stuff that charmed me charmed
me enough to be like oh yeah like
there's some stuff I think is really
cool about this like just that at least
the attention to detail the Karimun like
this is clearly made by people who care
about this yeah you know so I that stuff
endeared me and the fact that it wasn't
as madcap about the comedy also endeared
me I like seeing him in a new pace so
there is stuff that I think do draw me
in other than just like I'll check it
out isn't it alright guys what hey still
appreciate you sending that our way I
only know what trends are out when you
guys tell us so thank you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell dad John Humphrey is
dad John Humphrey Goodes Graham a
Twitter social media manager of Blum
house.com
and go check out our patreon just did a
Google hangout today anything you guys
go over there whatever reward you want
to get still contributes to this channel
keep it running keeping it alive right
now here so much left and everyone who's
over there and much less anyone who just
decided to give it a gander or just ask
someone if they are enjoying it I'll
tell you I'm pretty sure they'll tell
you yes we're very interactive over
there we get massages